Mexico City what were you doing that I  was taking some overdue holiday  it's obviously massively important the  opening Bible movie works we wanted to  do something extra special exposition is  unnecessary because that's been taken  care of over the last 52 years we can go  straight into it and that's what the  opening sequences usually do in a Bond  movie it's really great because it sets  the tone for the rest of the film then  coming to Mexico City before it is an  amazing location when I saw the frost 10  minutes I was amazed show the beauty of  Mexico City it's been a long time  finally the real so just watching to  know that was real this is no CGI and  they had thousands of extras I mean this  is a lot that went into this so it's  just amazing it just adds that much more  to  you